participation de la société civile à
l'oeuvre de justice n'est pas chose
nouvelle
et allah de longue date fait ses preuves
en france c'est vrai tant en matière
civile par exemple du conseil de
prud'hommes des tribunaux de commerce
des tribunaux paritaires des baux ruraux
notamment qu'en matière pénale avec des
quads assises des tribunaux pour enfants
et les chambres d'application des peines
cette participation est le fruit de
notre histoire directement héritée de la
révolution française
cette pratique est également courante
chez nos voisins étrangers certains
ayant notamment opter pour une présence
de la société civile dans les formations
de jugement des délits
c'est le cas notamment en allemagne en
autriche danemark en finlande norvège ou
en suède
associer des citoyens au jugement des
délits les plus graves et au suivi de
l'application des peines comme le
prévoit ce texte célia sur confrontés
les auteurs présumés au regard direct de
la société s'est par ailleurs permettre
aux citoyens de participer plus
largement à une justice qui est rendue à
leur nom et à cette guerre c'est la
marque head d'un engagement civique fort
et je pense que la plupart d'entre vous
ont lu ce matin d'un journal libération
le témoignage extrêmement intéressante
d'un jeune homme de 34 ans enseignant
qui a été juré et qui explique son
expérience de juré dans un journal de ce
matin
il dit notamment faire partie d'un jury
populaire
c'est la seule façon que nous ayons
aujourd'hui d'expérimenter directement
la démocratie on se sent responsable
dira que c'est démago c'est bidon dans
ce cas on peut renoncer à toute
expérience de démocratie directe
vous trouverez ce témoignage d'un
journal libération de ce matin de sueur
je suis sûr vous l'avez déjà lu mais
comme il ne doit pas dire ce que vous
voulez
ça va pas bien et c'est vrai que les
magistrats il faut bien un peu
voilà c est bien entendu enrichir les
formations de jugement de la présence de
la société civile car les magistrats
bénéficieront du regard neuf de ses
représentants c est pour le dire d'un
mot le gage d'une justice plus proche
moins formel plus en prise avec les
attentes des français
le même jeune enseignant dit un peu plus
loin dans son témoignage que soulever la
complexité pour les gens de mettre entre
entre parenthèses leur vie
professionnelle pour être jurés en
correctionnelle ça ne nous convainc pas
oui ça peut être compliqué mais c'est
aussi ça appartenir à une démocratie
je crois que ce jeune homme explique
particulièrement bien quel est l'objet
premier de ce texte
donc je ferai moins bien que lui mais je
vais quand même et essayer et de vous
donner et la substantifique moelle d'un
ce projet cette réforme va forcément
modifier les pratiques et des magistrats
professionnels dans le sens d'une
justice plus intelligibles pour nos
concitoyens
elle permettra également aux citoyens de
mieux appréhender l'office du juge de se
réapproprier les décisions de justice et
à 6,2 rapprocher justice et société
civile
tout d'abord au sein des tribunaux
correctionnels les citoyens assesseurs
participeront dès la première instance
au jugement des délits qui portent
quotidiennement atteinte à la sécurité
et à la tranquillité
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez élargi
le champ de compétences de formation
comprenant deux citoyens assesseurs afin
de lui donner plus de clarté et de
cohérence
ainsi cette formation sera compétente
dès la première instance pour tous les
délits d'atteintes aux personnes à leur
intégrité physique ou morale alors
identité ou à leur environnement
sous réserve bien sûr dans chacun de ces
cas que la peine encourue soit
supérieure ou égale à cinq ans et étant
réservée est la compétence du juge
unique par rapport au projet initial du
gouvernement
l'extension du périmètre de compétences
portent notamment et à titre d'exemple
sur toute question relative à la
détention ou l'enregistrement aide
images pédopornographiques à
l'administration de substance nuisible
aux abus de faiblesse au délaissement de
mineurs aggravés au traitement illégal
de données à caractère personnel à
l'usurpation d'identité ou délit
d'atteinte environnement unis de plus de
5 ans je me réjouis avec la logique du
projet de loi soit maintenu et même
renforcée du fait de cet élargissement
de compétences des citoyens assesseurs
ne participeront en revanche pas au
jugement des contentieux spécialisés qui
depuis plusieurs années maintenant sont
en raison de leur particulière
technicité confiait des magistrats
spécialisés rompue aux subtilités
juridiques et techniques de ces
procédures
je rappelle que nous allemands poursuit
ce mouvement de spécialisation des
contentieux les plus complexes
dernièrement dans le projet de loi
relatif à la répartition des contentieux
et à l'allègement des procédures
juridictionnelles qui était examinée et
approuvée par m a semblé la composition
des formations de jugement conformément
aux exigences constitutionnelles qui
impose une majorité de magistrats
professionnels consistera donc un
collège de cinq personnes comprenant
trois magistrats et deux citoyens
assesseurs
j'insiste sur ce point et d'unicité de
la formation est préservé il n'y aura
pas d'une hta les magistrats
professionnels d'autre part des citoyens
assesseurs
il y aura cinq personnes amenées d'antan
d'une audience à juger ensemble une
série d'affaires qui chacune ont le même
poids lors du délibéré
plusieurs garanties procédurales sont
prévus à cet effet le texte prévoit
ensuite la participation de citoyens
assesseurs auprès des magistrats du
tribunal d'application des peines et des
chambres d'application des peines pour
toutes les décisions modifiant ou
aménageant un des peines que la
libération conditionnelle de relèvement
de la période de sûreté des leurs que la
peine prononcée est supérieure à cinq
ans d'emprisonnement
il est en effet apparu légitime
d'associer les citoyens à des décisions
qu'ils portent
20 % d'entre elles modifient l'exécution
de peines rendus par les cours d'assises
donc par des formations comprenant un
des jurés la procédure de sélection et
des citoyens assesseurs repose sur le
principe du tirage au sort à partir des
listes préparatoires au jury d'assises
elle est assortie de mécanismes
permettant de s'assurer que les citoyens
tirés au sort sont aptes à participer à
l'acte de juger ces garanties sont
renforcées par rapport à celles exigées
pour les jurés en effet les citoyens
appelés à siéger deux peuvent être
récusé en début d'audience comme c'est
le cas pour et jurés d'assises et ils
font partie intégrante de la formation
appelée à juger au même titre que les
magistrats la commission des lois a
utilement simplifier les modalités de
désignation des citoyens assesseurs
même si je regrette qu'elle n'ait pas
souhaité conserver et les garanties
d'impartialité et de moralité que nous
avions expressément mentionnée mais
pense que cela est sous-entendu dans
décision de la commission et qu'elle
trouvera l'occasion de revenir sur ces
deux poids d'ailleurs le soutien du
gouvernement
je rappelle que les citoyens retenus ne
pourront pas se soustraire à ce devoir
civique sous peine d'amendé et je
rappelle que leur participation sera de
courte durée
huit journées d'audience sur l'année et
qu'elle sera naturellement à indemniser
je sais être naturellement que certaines
interrogations pratiques ont été
exprimés la première portion des moyens
accompagnant la réforme la seconde sur
l'allongement des procédures que
pourrait entraîner la présence des
citoyens assesseurs sur le premier poids
nous nous évaluerons environ à 40 mille
par an le nombre d'affaires jugement dès
qu'elles participeront les citoyens
cette réforme sera donc accompagné comme
je me suis engagé du recrutement de 155
magistrats et 208 greffiers il ya
d'ailleurs deux concours de recrutement
exceptionnel qui sont prévues pour les
magistrats et pour les greffiers
dès cette année sur le second point il
est évident il y aura un allongement de
la procédure le lier serait totalement
faux mais c'est aussi naturellement le
prix à payer à cette démocratisation de
la justice par ailleurs sur le second
point je suis pleinement favorable à la
proposition de monsieur zocchetto adopté
par la commission des lois en matière de
comparution immédiate qui vise à réduire
le délai de présentation devant le
tribunal correctionnel de 1 mois à 8
jours s'agit là d'un poids d'équilibré
entre la nécessité nécessité de pouvoir
conserver et les modes rapide de
poursuites pour ces délits tout en
évitant un accroissement des cas de
détention provisoire je crois d'une
façon générale qu'il nous faut adopter
une démarche pragmatique sur ce
dispositif nouveau et c'est bien
pourquoi nous avons retenu le principe
d'une mise en oeuvre progressive de la
loi comme le permet l'article 37 1 de la
constitution
cette phase d'expérimentation débutera
dès le 1er janvier 2012 dans deux cours
d'appel pour s'étendre à un tiers du
territoire
l'année suivante début 2013 nous
permettra d'évaluer avec plus de
précision avant l'entrée en vigueur
définitive du texte qui est prévue pour
le 1er janvier 2014
l'impact de la réforme notamment sur
l'organisation un des audiences
enfin un je veux insister sur le fait
que la participation des citoyens
assesseurs supposera à n'en pas douter
un effort de pédagogie de la part des
magistrats qui prendra sans doute du
temps et qui concourra à la meilleure
compréhension des décisions de justice
comme je n'ai dit la procédure sera
adapté à cette fin avec notamment un
exposé oral de la faire par le président
pour permettre dès le début de l'examen
du dossier à tous les assesseurs de
disposer d'une connaissance complète de
la faire le second point du projet de
loi et lui relatif à l'amélioration du
fonctionnement des assises et c'est
d'abord sur ce point que le gouvernement
a fait un pas
vers la commission des lois qui
elle-même at-elle fait à verdun
gouvernement pour que dès le premier un
premier routeur les jurés soient
présents en correctionnelle quel est le
but
il s'agit de simplifier la procédure d
asile gagner du temps pour réduire la
correctionnalisation des crimes
un des problèmes que nous connaissons
dans notre pays c'est que chaque année
des cours d'assises traite d'environ
2400 va faire plus 200 affaires en appel
à peu près et que la majorité des créer
une très grande majorité des crimes sont
déclassées en quelque sorte pour être
correctionnalisé est jugé par les
tribunaux correctionnels est il y a en
plus une différenciation d'appréciation
suivant les départements
lorsqu'il y à beaucoup d'affaires
criminelles
il ya beaucoup de correctionnalisations
et puis lorsqu'il ya peu d'affaires
criminelles dans un département
la cour d'assises siègent tous les trois
mois comme la loi le prévoit
et elle épuise pratiquement le rôle des
affaires criminelles et qu'il ya donc
cette inégalité devant la loi pénale de
nos concitoyens sur des points
particulièrement important notamment le
viol ou très souvent au disqualifie le
viol d'agression sexuelle et il devient
il passe de crime à delhi et il n'est
plus jugé par la cour d'assises mai par
le tribunal correctionnel pour lutter
contre cette pratique de
correctionnalisations nous souhaitions
pouvoir de rendre plus efficace plus
rapide
la procédure devant la cour d'assises
alors pour cela nous avons essayé de
simplifier et les choses et nous sommes
tombés d'accord gouvernement et
commission des lois pour privilégier une
modification du nombre des jurés sans
distinguer les catégories
de crime en première instance il y aura
trois magistrats professionnels et six
jurés et en appel trois magistrats
professionnels et neuf jurés
c'est bien que nous restons fidèles à la
règle selon laquelle la décision de
condamner peut être prise par l'essonne
injures et non magistrats
les chiffres eux le montre et m jury
avec une autre proposition et du
gouvernement qui a été adopté par votre
commission qui va permettre de gagner
beaucoup de temps et apporter de la
clarté aux débats il s'agit du
remplacement de la lecture souvent
fastidieuse de l'arrêt de renvoi par un
rapport fait par le président en début
d'audience
associer ces mesures permettront de
limiter et les correctionnalisation et
puis il y à une autre novation dans le
texte relatif aux assises c'est
l'obligation pour les assises de modifie
et de pardon et de motiver leur décision
le conseil constitutionnel dans sa
récente décision sur cette question qui
date du 1er avril
un dernier a considéré que notre
procédure d'assises qui prévoit que la
réponse à une série de questions étaient
conformes à la constitution il n'y avait
donc pas d'obligation pour le
gouvernement de proposer au parlement de
légiférer et pour le parlement de
légiférer
néanmoins et nous paraît utile de
permettre à toutes les parties de
connaître le raisonnement qui a conduit
la cour a condamné ou acquitté tout en
respectant bien sûr le secret du
délibéré et l'intimé conviction
fondement du système du jury d'assises
ceci permettra notamment de prendre la
décision d'un éventuel appel pourrait
parties concernées en pleine
connaissance de cause
le président de la cour d'assises
réalisera donc une note qui synthétisera
les débats enfin dans son dernier volet
le projet de loi modifie leur donnant du
2 février 1945 sur la justice pénale des
mineurs
les réflexions sur l'amélioration d'un
justice pénale des mineurs
son temps sièges peut-être la 32e 33e
modification de l'ordonnancé de 1945
le gouvernement avait d'ailleurs confié
au recteur andré varinard en 2008 de
présidence d'une commission qui était
chargé de formuler des propositions
relatives à reconstruire quelque sorte
le droit pénal des mineurs
ces travaux se sont poursuivis et qu'un
projet de refonte complète de
l'ordonance de 1901 45 et il s'agissait
donc dans l'esprit du gouvernement de
proposer une véritable véritable code de
justice pénale des mineurs
cependant ce code dont l'album dont la
partie technique de l'élaboration est
quasiment achevée ne peut se concevoir
qu en adéquation avec une réforme
globale de la procédure pénale que le
prochain terme de cette législature ne
permet pas d'envisager et donc cependant
apparu nécessaire au gouvernement de
procéder dès à présent à plusieurs
modifications de ce texte de 1945 pour
renforcer la qualité des réponses
par exemple avec la création du dossier
unique de personnalité
il s'agit également de rendre cette
justice plus rapide
le délai moyen entre la commission des
fêtes art mineur et le jugement par un
tribunal pour enfants est actuellement
de plus de 18 mois est d'adapter et ce
système à une délinquance plus violente
qui est le fait de mineurs de plus en
plus jeunes le texte respecte pleinement
les principes de la justice des mineurs
tels qu'ils ont été consacrés par le
conseil constitutionnel à savoir la
priorité donnée à l'éducatif la
spécialisation des structures et des
procédures protectrice telle qu'elle
prévoit à la fois la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 29 août 2002 et la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant qui était signée par la france
et bien entendu les excuses
de minorités qui n'est en rien modifié
par ce texte
tout d'abord pour une meilleure prise de
conscience des fêtes commis par les
mineurs et donc pour prévenir des
risques de récidive le projet de loi
donne la possibilité aux parquets de
convoquer directement un mineur devant
le tribunal pour enfants par oued
convocation par un officier de police
judiciaire
tirant les conséquences de la décision
du conseil constitutionnel du 11 mars
dernier et nous avons assorti cette
convocation de toutes les garanties
requises
le texte prévoit donc pour recourir à
cette procédure
un seuil d'âge minimum un niveau de
gravité des fêtes ainsi qu'un délai
maximal de deux mois pour la tenue de
l'audience et enfin la présence d'
éléments récents de personnalités sur ce
dernier point votre commission a estimé
que la saisine du tribunal pour enfants
par convocation par officier de police
judiciaire ou par la procédure
présentation immédiate qui exige une
complète information du tribunal sur la
personnalité du mineur poursuivi ne
saurait être possible si ces
informations provenant du seul recueil
de renseignements socio éducatif
cependant il peut être utile de prévoir
quelles investigations sur la
personnalité puisse résulter de ce
recueil de renseignements socio éducatif
dès lors que ces investigations ont été
suffisantes
il faut également que les circonstances
des poursuites en l'espèce une
succession d'infraction commise par le
mineur justifie je vous proposerai donc
par voie d'amendement de revenir sur ce
point en précisant que seul un mineur
qui fait l'objet ou a déjà fait l'objet
d'une où plusieurs procédures pourraient
être poursuivis à un convocation
officier de police judiciaire
le but n'est pas en effet de permettre
l'utilisation de cette provocation à
l'égard des mineurs qui ne se sont pas
déjà qu'ils sont pas parents ont déjà
connu de la justice mais de là réservées
aux mineurs qui ont déjà fait l'objet
par exemple d'une composition pénale ou
d'une convocation devant le juge des
enfants
pour autant il n'est pas possible
d'attendre que ces procédures et abouti
à une condamnation définitive
li qu'elle est même déjà permis des
investigations approfondies une telle
exigence interdirait convocation par
officier de police judiciaire à l'égard
des mineurs qui multiplie la commission
d'infractions dans un court laps de
temps
or cette situation est fréquente et à
une période de leur adolescence où
certains mineurs multiplient et les
délits le texte contient deux autres
d'évolutions majeures afin de mieux
répondre aux évolutions de la
délinquance et de lutter contre la
récidive
tout d'abord il s'agit de
l'élargissement des possibilités de
placement en centre éducatif fermé
le projet de loi prévoit d'abaisser du
fait à 5 ans le seuil de la peine
encourue qui autorise le placement en
centre éducatif fermé
me dire que ces centres ont démontré
leur efficacité notamment s'agissant de
la lutte contre la récidive
ainsi plus des deux tiers des mineurs
souvent difficiles qui en sortent ne
récidive pas à l'année suivante
cette prise en charge pluridisciplinaire
très renforcée mérite donc d'être étendu
à des mineurs même primo délinquants qui
commettent des faits graves pour mieux
répondre à la problématique de récidive
le texte crée par ailleurs un tribunal
correctionnel pour mineurs qui jugera
les mineurs délinquants en état de
récidive de plus de 16 ans dès lors
qu'ils encourent une peine supérieure à
trois ans d'emprisonnement à la
progressivité de la sanction doit
correspondre la même progression dans
les formations de jugement compétente
pour connaître des mineurs ainsi cette
nouvelle juridiction apportera une
réponse mieux adaptée du fait de sa plus
grande solennité et de sa charge
symbolique elle pourra prononcer des
sanctions éducatives
si elles le jugent suffisants la
commission des lois du sénat a en outre
souhaité qu'elle soit présidée par le
juge de l'enfant puisqu'il ya
obligatoirement un juge des enfants qui
siègera dans ce tribunal et vous avez
souhaité que celui qui préside le
tribunal correctionnel pour préserver la
spécificité de la justice
binner j'ajoute d'ailleurs que la
procédure qui sera suivie devant ce
tribunal est celle du tribunal pour
enfants et pas la procédure de droit
commun
troisièmement enfin le texte du projet
de loi comporte par ailleurs un
dispositif visant à mieux prendre en
compte la personnalité du mineur
délinquant s'agit de la création du
dossier unique de personnalité
c'est une demande forte des
professionnels temps éducatif que
judiciaire il rassemblera l'ensemble des
éléments relatifs à la personnalité de
mineurs recueillis soit l'occasion d'une
procédure pénale soit l'occasion
d'assistance éducatif et ce dossier
unique de personnalité sera une
connaissance plus approfondie du mineur
délinquant pour un meilleur suivi et une
meilleure cohérence des décisions le
concernant
il répondra aux règles fixées par la loi
informatique et liberté de 1978
c'est comme ces conditions de
conservation et d'archivage est
indéfinie par voie réglementaire après
avis de la cnil
l'aïe a vocation à être utilisé que pour
les procédure suivie devant les
juridictions pour mineurs il ne sera
conservé
après la majorité que pour permettre le
jugement de faits commis avant ou pour
assurer un suivi jusqu'à 21 ans maximum
du mineur par le juge des enfants dans
le cadre de ses fonctions d'application
des peines il s'agit donc ici
typiquement d'une mesure qui synthétise
l'esprit dans lequel ce projet de loi a
été élaboré pouvoir juger dans les
meilleures conditions et notamment avec
une connaissance plus aigu de la
personnalité les mineurs délinquants
tout en respectant l'exigence de
célérité qui permet de pleinement son
sens à la sanction
le texte prévoit enfin un renforcement
de la responsabilité des parents en
ouvrant la possibilité de délivrer comme
pour les témoins un ordre de comparaître
afin de les contraindre à assister à
l'audience
le parent n'hésite pas en effet le
témoin essentiel de la personnalité d'un
mineur il est important d'impliquer les
parents dans la procédure pour donner sa
pleine portée aux décisions de justice
et leur faire prendre conscience de
l'importance
leur application je voudrais pour
conclure maintenant revenir sur
l'intérêt d'une participation des
citoyens aux décisions de justice pénale
en ne doutant pas que comme cela se
pratique dans la cour d'assises depuis
plus de deux siècles les débats
judiciaires correspondent à la
description et qu'on faisait andré gide
dans son introduction des souvenirs
d'accord d'acide majid écrivait ce qui
va peut-être le plus frappé au cours de
ces séances
c'est la conscience avec laquelle chacun
temps juge qu'avec un juré s'acquitter
de ses fonctions
j'ai vraiment admiré à plus d'une
reprise la présence d'esprit du
président et sa connaissance du chat
café l'urgence de ces interrogations
la fermeté la modération d'accusation la
densité des plaidoiries et l'absence
veine d'éloquence enfin l'attention des
jurés je pense que par votre vote
j'en suis convaincu vous aurez à coeur
de rapprocher encore lé citoyen de leur
justice
et comme disait le jeune jurés quand je
suis tel témoignage dans libération ce
matin et concluait en disant dans tous
les cas ça contribuera à notre
apprentissage de la citoyenneté c'est
bien là le but poursuit le gouvernement
en soumettant ce texte à la haute
assemblée le grand merci merci je me
sens maintenant la parole et de notre
collègue jean rené lecerf rapporteur de
la commission des lois
le président monsieur le garde des
sceaux bis de justice et des libertés
mes chers collègues le projet de loi sur
la participation des citoyens au
fonctionnement de la justice pénale et
le jugement des mineurs dont le sénat
est saisie en première lecture et pour
lequel la procédure accélérée a été
engagée recouvre trois réformes
d'ampleur qui aurait pu justifier autant
de projets de loi distincts la
participation de citoyens assesseurs au
jugement de certains délits et aux
décisions concernant l'application des
peines la création d'une nouvelle
formation de la cour d'assises
la modification de plusieurs
dispositions importantes de l'
ordonnance du 2 février 45 relative à
l'enfance délinquante
la porte est notable des transformations
proposé doit cependant être relativisé
dans la mesure où s'agissant de la
participation de citoyens assesseurs aux
différentes juridictions pénales
l'application des dispositions du projet
de loi fera d'abord l'objet d'une
expérimentation dans le ressort d'un
nombre limité de cour d'appel jusqu'au
1er janvier 2014 puis le législateur se
prononcera sur la généralisation
éventuelle de ces innovations au vu de
l'expérimentation
si votre commission des lois qui s'est
vu imposer des délais d'examen de la
réforme très contraignants souscrits à
l'objectif d'une plus grande
participation des citoyens au
fonctionnement de la justice pénale
elle souhaite immédiatement dissiper une
ambiguïté fondamentale
l'enjeu de la réforme ne saurait être
celui d'une justice plus rigoureuse la
plus grande sévérité des citoyens au
regard des magistrats relèvent de l'idée
reçue pour ne pas dire de la contre
vérité
l'expérience comparer des jugements des
tribunaux correctionnels formé
aujourd'hui des seuls magistrats et des
cours d'assises avec jury peut utilement
nous éclairer depuis dix ans le quantum
des peines prononcées aux assises est
stable tandis que celui des peines
correctionnelles ne cesse d'augmenter
devant votre commission des lois le
garde des sceaux a rappelé aussi les
leçons de l'histoire
la spécialisation initiale des jurés
dans la décision relative à la
culpabilité laissant aux seuls juges
professionnels le choix de la peine à
mener bien souvent les jurés à ne pas
admettre une culpabilité pourtant
évidente
afin d'éviter des sanctions
excessivement lourde
c'est ainsi que le 19e siècle et le
début du xxème enregistre un taux
d'acquittement proche de 40%
il s'agit donc simplement d'encourager
l'appropriation par les citoyens des
décisions de justice au nom des
exigences de cohésion sociale et du
respect du pacte républicain
comme le souligne l'exposé des motifs du
projet de loi
l'ambition ultime résident dans la
réconciliation des français avec leur
justice
objectif essentiel de toute démocratie
apaisée
dans un sondage réalisé en mai 2008 par
l'ifop
à l'initiative du conseil supérieur de
la magistrature sur la confiance
accordée par le grand public à l'égard
des différentes institutions la justice
est largement dépassée par les hôpitaux
l'école l'armée la police ou la fonction
publique
elle précède cependant mes chers
collègues les élus avant derniers et les
médias lanterne rouge de ce redoutable
hit parade
si le texte proposé par le gouvernement
répond pour partie à cet objectif de
réconciliation des français avec leur
justice
il soulève cependant plusieurs
interrogations qui ont conduit votre
commission a proposé sur certains point
d équilibre différent
sur le premier volet du projet de loi
la participation des citoyens à la
justice pénale votre rapporteur n'a pas
rencontré beaucoup d'objection de
principe
la présence notamment de citoyens dans
les tribunaux correctionnels et une plus
large ouverture de la justice sur la
société figure tant dans les
revendications du syndicat de la
magistrature que dans la profession de
foi du candidat nicolas sarkozy aux
dernières élections présidentielles
cette référence d'une justice
démocratique fille de la révolution
n'est-elle pas aujourd'hui unanimement
apprécié dans l'opinion comme chez les
magistrats eux-mêmes
permettez moi de citer ici le témoignage
de monsieur jean pierre getti président
de la cour d'assises de paris qui
m'apparaît très représentatifs de
l'opinion de ses confrères la présence
des jurés pour l'examen et le jugement
des affaires criminelles est la
meilleure garantie que l'on puisse
offrir aux justiciables leurs
questionnements leur souci permanent de
ne pas commettre d'erreurs judiciaires
leur recherche de la juste peine créée
pour les magistrats professionnels une
remise en cause permanente de leurs
pratiques ainsi que la nécessité
d'expliquer voire de justifier leurs
prises de positions sur les différents
aspects de la faire ceci favorise une
absence de routine extrêmement bénéfique
à la prise de décision finale fin de
citation si les vertus des jurés sont
elles pourquoi ne pas leur donner une
plus large place
rappelons encore que l'association des
citoyens à la justice pénale se
rattachent à deux modèles tout d'abord
celui du jurés tirés au sort qui remplit
une mission brève mais intense et
dispose d'un pouvoir décisionnel
autonome ensuite celui de l'esj vent qui
se porte candidat par sa compétence
particulière en un domaine et intervient
de manière ponctuelle mais durable
s'agissant du premier
la loi du 28 juillet 10 978 ce n'est pas
si ancien à parachever la
démocratisation du jury d'assises
en posant le principe d'un tirage au
sort à tous les stades du recrutement en
partant des listes électorales la
présomption d'infaillibilité du jury
émanation du peuple souverain a
longtemps justifié l'absence d'un second
d'un second degré de juridiction pour
les crimes
après les chefs du texte de jacques
toubon en 96 en raison de la dissolution
de l'assemblée nationale de 97
il a fallu attendre la loi du 15 juin
2000 pour que ce projet aboutisse à
l'initiative de votre commission des
lois
depuis l'existence d'une cour d'assises
d'appel composée de douze jurés au lieu
de neuf
a démontré son utilité je vous renvoie
par exemple à l' affaire d'outreau le
modèle de l'échevin qui repose sur la
sélection des candidatures s'incarne
dans la ses soeurs du tribunal pour
enfants et du tribunal correctionnel de
la nouvelle calédonie dont le juge de
proximité ou encore dans la
participation de deux représentants de
la société civile à la formation élargie
de la chambre d'application des peines
la participation des citoyens à la
justice pénale
objet de controverses et parfois
contournées je pense à l'instauration de
cour d'assises sans jury pour les
infractions militaires et celles en
matière de sûreté de l'état de
terrorisme et le trafic de stupéfiants
et surtout à la correctionnalisation des
affaires criminelles
ce phénomène concernerait près de la
moitié des crimes voire les deux tiers
d'entre eux le conseil constitutionnel a
rappelé que la proportion de juges non
professionnels doit rester minoritaire
dans les formations correctionnel de
droit commun
cette réserve d'interprétation ne vaut
pas pour les cours d'assises dont la
composition répondent à une double
exigence d'indépendance et de capacités
garantie par le tirage au sort et les
conditions d'aptitude est renforcée par
le système de récusation
en outre note-t-on dans l'étude d'impact
l'ancienneté de la cour d'assises et le
lien étroit entre le jurait est
l'expression de la souveraineté
populaire pourrait conduire à voir dans
l'institution du jury un principe
fondamental reconnu par les lois de la
république
le projet vise le projet de loi vise
d'une part à mieux représenter les
citoyens dans les tribunaux
correctionnels et les juridictions de
l'application des peines
d'autre part à créer une formation
allégée de la cour d'assises pour
simplifier l'organisation de la justice
ce double objectif s'appuie sur la
création de la nouvelle catégorie du
citoyen assesseur qui se situe entre le
jurés des cours d'assises et le juge de
proximité
de fait son mode de désignation combine
le tirage au sort et une sélection
fondée sur certains critères d'aptitude
étude et d'impartialité l'inscription
sur la liste annuelle des citoyens
assesseurs résulte d'un choix en
fonction de plusieurs critères
satisfaire les conditions requises pour
être juré mais aussi présenter des
garanties d'impartialité et de moralité
comment évaluer ces critères les
citoyens tirés au sort sur les listes
préparatoires recevront un questionnaire
mais alors celui ci peut se révéler
intrusif la commission départementale
pourra procéder ou faire procéder à
l'audition des personnes qui n'auraient
pas répondu ou aurait répondu de manière
incomplète à ce questionnaire enfin la
commission pour inscrire une personne
sur la liste annuelle devra procéder une
enquête relative à la moralité et à
l'impartialité de l'intéressé le projet
de loi conduit ainsi à créer pas moins
de six nouvelles formations de jugement
dont une pour le jugement des mineurs
tout d'abord deux formations en matière
correctionnelle
composée de trois magistrats
professionnels et de deux citoyens
assesseurs le tribunal correctionnel
citoyen si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
compétent pour juger des faits de
violences contre les personnes punies de
cinq à sept ou dix ans d'emprisonnement
relevant actuellement du tribunal
correctionnel collégial et la chambre d
appel pour statuer sur l'appel formé
contre une décision rendue par ce
tribunal correctionnel citoyen ensuite
une nouvelle formation de la cour
d'assises au premier degré composée elle
aussi de trois magistrats et deux
citoyens assesseurs dotée d'une
compétence de principe pour les crimes
passibles de 15 et 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle commis en l'absence de
récidive
le procureur de la république ou la
puisaye non la partie civile pourrait
toujours demander le jugement par une
cour d'assises composée d'un juré ne se
croit le texte modifie la procédure
devant la cour d'assises
quelle que soit sa formation sur deux
points la suppression de la lecture par
le greffier de la décision de renvoi qui
pouvaient durer plusieurs jours
au bénéfice d'un exposé du président et
la motivation des décisions criminelle
en bref nous aurons si nous aurions si
vous me pardonnez la familiarité de
l'expression
une cour d'assises light où siégeront
deux citoyens assesseurs et une cour
d'assises hard ou les jurés seront
majoritaires de nouvelles formations
sont également prévus pour l'application
des peines
le tribunal de l'application des peines
comprendra deux citoyens assesseurs
lorsqu'il se prononce sur le relèvement
de la période de sûreté ainsi que sur
les libérations conditionnelles
il aura compétence sur les décisions
impliquant des personnes condamnées à
une peine égale ou supérieure à cinq ans
de même que la chambre de l'application
des peines à la place des deux
représentants des associations
aujourd'hui lorsqu'elle statuts sont les
décisions de ce tribunal la mise en
oeuvre globale de la réforme à partir du
1er janvier 2014 rendra nécessaire sur
la base des hypothèses retenues dans
l'étude d'impact la mobilisation de plus
de 32 millions d'euros en crédits
d'investissement et plus de huit
millions d'euros en crédits de
fonctionnement indemnisation des
citoyens assesseurs incluse
ceci sans tenir compte des 155 postes de
magistrats et 110 postes de greffiers
dont le garde des sceaux a obtenu la
création
votre rapporteur a cherché à conforter
les objectifs poursuivis par le projet
de loi
en simplifiant le mode de désignation
des citoyens assesseurs en élargissant
le champ de compétence du tribunal
correctionnel citoyen et concernant la
cour d'assises en réaffirmant le pouvoir
des jurés populaires et le refus de la
scission du statut de la cour d'assises
sur le jugement des crimes
votre commission a souhaité maintenir
les grands principes gouvernant les
assises elle s'étonnait que dans le
cadre d'une réforme justifiée par une
meilleure participation citoyenne l'on
commence par remplacer neuf jurés par
deux citoyens assesseurs dans près de
90% des affaires criminelles en première
instance elle regrettait également
l'alignement de la nouvelle formation de
la cour d'assises alléger sur celle du
tribunal correctionnel comprenant des
citoyens assesseurs dans la volonté
d'éviter la correctionnalisation des
crimes
on en venait largement à une certaine
forme de correctionnalisations des
assises votre commission a donc choisi
de simplifier
le système existant sans remettre en
cause les principes de base
elle a ainsi réduit l'effectif du jury
de 9 à 6 en première instance et de 12 à
9 en appel ce qui permet d'une part de
garantir la prépondérance des jurés par
rapport aux magistrats et d'autre part
de préserver la règle d'une majorité
qualifiée pour obtenir la condamnation
de l'accusé sur le jugement des délits
votre commission a souhaité élargir le
périmètre des compétences de la
formation comportant deux citoyens
assesseurs à l'ensemble des atteintes
aux personnes passibles d'une peine
d'emprisonnement égales ou supérieures à
5 ans compte tenu des enjeux que
représentent les questions
d'environnement pour la société il est
apparu également justifié d'ajouter les
infractions au code de l'environnement
passible de la même manière d'une peine
égale ou supérieure à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement
votre rapporteur lors des auditions
avait perçu la crainte de distinguer en
quelque sorte un contentieux des pauvres
avec la présence des citoyens assesseurs
d'un contentieux des riches jugé
uniquement par des magistrats
professionnels
au-delà de l'aspect caricatural de ce
reproche votre rapporteur est convaincu
que le bon sens des citoyens assesseurs
peut s'avérer utile et nécessaire au
delà des seuls problèmes de violences
aux personnes
la présence de citoyens assesseurs au
sein des tribunaux et de la chambre
d'application des peines est apparue
justifier à votre commission elle
permettra de consacrer l'intervention
citoyenne pour remettre en cause les
peines prononcées par un jury populaire
et qui tiennent à coeur à la société je
ne crois nullement impossible en outre
d' expliquer à l'opinion comme aux
futurs citoyens assesseurs que la
libération conditionnelle par exemple
jouent un rôle essentiel dans la
réinsertion qui demeure l'objectif
essentiel à poursuivre je rappelle à
cette occasion que la lutte contre la
récidive et les actions de réinsertion
sont aussi indissociables que l'avers et
le revers de la même médaille
second volet du texte une vingtaine de
propositions visant à adapter
l'ordonance du vin du 2 février 45
relative à l'enfance délinquante pour
une réponse judiciaire plus rapide et
plus lisible entre 2002 et 2009 le
nombre de mineurs mis en cause par les
services de police et de gendarmerie a
crû de 19% mais contre 32 % chez les
majeurs clou de ces mineurs réitère
cette mineure sur dix ne font pas
l'objet de nouvelles poursuites ou d'une
mesure alternative aux poursuites dans
l'année suivant la fin de leur prise en
charge
en revanche un petit noyau de 5 %
seraient responsables de près de la
moitié des infractions commises
la justice des mineurs en france n'est
pas particulièrement laxiste mais
erratique
aujourd'hui en dépit de neuf
modifications apportées à l'ordonnancé
de 45 depuis 2002 ce constat dressé par
la commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
délinquance des mineurs et par son
rapporteur notre collègue jean claude
carle
il y a neuf ans est encore largement
partagé le principal grief est celui de
la lenteur entre les faits et la
condamnation définitive par le juge ou
le tribunal c'est cool 18 mois 5 ans
pour la condamnation par une cour
d'assises dès mineurs
autre difficulté le manque cruel de
lisibilité et de cohérence
depuis 45 l'ordonance a fait l'objet de
34 modifications sans que son
architecture fasse l'objet d'une refonte
d'ensemble à la demande du gouvernement
une commission présidée par le recteur
andré varinard a remis un rapport en
décembre 2008
préconisant entre autres l'élaboration
d'un code de la justice pénale des
mineurs
l'avant projet de loi qui l'a inspiré
sera discutée a fait valoir le
gouvernement en liaison avec la réforme
de l'ensemble de la procédure pénale
pour l'heure son examen par le parlement
a donc été repoussée aussi le
gouvernement at il jugé nécessaire de
modifier dès à présent l'ordonance de 45
premier objectif renforcer l'efficacité
de la chaîne pénale
la création du dossier unique de
personnalité qui rassemblera toutes les
investigations sur la personnalité du
mineur mettra la juridique
en mesure de statuer en pleine
connaissance de cause y compris
lorsqu'elle est saisie par une procédure
rapide de poursuites
la procédure de convocation par officier
de police judiciaire devant le tribunal
pour enfants permettra de juger les
mineurs déjà connu de l'institution
judiciaire dans un délai bref
corrélativement la procédure de
convocation par opg devant le juge des
enfants au fameux jugement peut utiliser
est supprimé enfin le texte prévoit un
nouveau tribunal correctionnel pour
mineurs compétent pour juger les mineurs
de 16 à 18 ans ayant commis des délits
en état de récidive légale
deuxième objectif accroître l'éventail
des outils à la disposition des
magistrats afin d'adapter la réponse
finale à la personnalité des mineurs
désormais la juridiction de jugement
pourra sortir une peine d'une sanction
éducative
de même le texte facilite le placement
des mineurs en centre éducatif fermé et
encadre l'assignation à résidence avec
surveillance électronique
enfin le juge des enfants pourra
convertir une peine d'emprisonnement
ferme de faibles quantum en travail
d'intérêt général pour un mineur de plus
de saison troisième objectif renforcer
l'implication des parents défaillants
ceux ci seront systématiquement informés
des décisions de l'autorité judiciaire
et les juridictions pourront délivrer un
ordre de comparaître à leur rencontre
afin de les contraindre à assister à
l'audience
les représentants légaux du mineur
seront également jugés par jugements
contradictoires a signifié et non plus
par défaut
votre rapporteur et votre commission
plutôt favorable à ces dispositions ont
estimé que les procédures rapides de
poursuite devait se faire à la condition
que la juridiction dispose
d'investigations approfondies et
récentes sur la personnalité du mineur
cette clarification est nécessaire
d'autant plus compte tenu de la censure
du conseil constitutionnel de la loppsi
2 conformément à l'exigence
constitutionnelle de spécialisation des
juridictions pour mineurs le tribunal
correctionnel pour mineurs doit selon la
commission être présidé par un juge des
enfants
enfin nous prévoyons que la victime sera
systématiquement informés de la date de
jugement afin de pouvoir se constituer
partie civile
ce président est monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues avant de conclure
cette intervention je tiens à remercier
le garde des sceaux pour les coudes qui
a été la sienne dans le travail en
commun avec la commission des lois
je doute croit pouvoir assurer que
gouvernement et commission des lois ont
fait effectivement un certain nombre de
gestes les uns vers les autres de façon
à aboutir à ce texte qui me semble
équilibré que nous vous présentons
aujourd'hui est que la commission vous
demande en tenant compte bien évidemment
de ces abondements de bien vouloir
adopter
je vous remercie merci la bande à
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois ou souhaitez intervenir vous
avez la parole et merci monsieur le
président pour faciliter nos débats lors
de l'examen du titre ii du projet de loi
qui porterait dispositions modifiant
l'ordonnancé du 2 février 45 relatives à
l'enfance délinquance la commission des
lois souhaiterait que soient examinés en
priorité les articles 17 et 29
je rappelle que ces artistes seraient
donc discuté au début du titre de juste
avant l'article 10 la priorité de droit
lorsqu'elle est demandée par la
commission saisie au fond quel est
l'avis du gouvernement avis favorable
donc cette demande est acceptée
maintenant nous allons entrer dans le
vif de la discussion générale
la parole est à notre collègue alain
anziani pour le groupe socialiste il
dispose de dix minutes
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues
d'abord un petit rappel de l'histoire
l'an passé
la réforme de la procédure pénale était
une urgence mais ce n'était pas la même
urgence que celle d'aujourd'hui
à l'époque cette urgence décidée par le
président de la république consistait à
supprimer le juge d'instruction et même
à mettre en place une procédure
accusatoire dont nous voyons en ce
moment même les effets en juillet
dernier le conseil constitutionnel
imposait une autre urgence qui n'était
pas la même cette urgence était de
réformer la garde à vue à la française
que nous dénoncions depuis des années
mais que depuis des années la
chancellerie s'obstinait à considérer
comme parfaite en tous points et
aujourd'hui une troisième urgence vient
chasser les deux autres il serait
nécessaire de réformer la procédure
d'audience et la justice dès mai d'un
des mineurs en vitesse accélérée et en
tout cas avant l'été
alors j'ai essayé de comprendre quel est
le motif de cette accélération des
dernières semaines
motif qui n'est d'ailleurs pas à
partager non plus par notre rapporteur
qui tout à l'heure à dénoncer les délais
qui nous ont été imposées pour examiner
des textes qui sont quand même d'une
certaine importance
j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit mais cette
réforme bien sans doute d'une
concertation approfondie avec les
professionnels concernés et notamment
avec la commission léger qui avait été
mis en place pour justement essayer
d'examiner une réforme de la procédure
pénale
et bien malheureusement ce n'est pas le
cas ce texte n'est pas nous est pas
arrivé à la suite d'une concertation
mais par un soir de
d'émissions télévisées on aurait pu
penser derrière que dans cette émission
télévisée ce sera et et vous monsieur le
garde des sceaux qui auriez fait
l'annnonce de cette nécessité et bien
non c était l'oeuvre du mist de
l'intérieur et je voudrais vous saluer
monsieur le garde des sceaux
immédiatement vous avez d'ailleurs réagi
en disant eh bien il faut tempérer
l'ardeur de mon collègue l'intérieur et
vous nous avait précisé que les nouveaux
jurés ne siégerait pas en appel oui mais
voilà le texte aujourd'hui devant les
yeux et en fin de compte on voit que le
ministre de l'intérieur l'a emporté il y
aura deux jurés populaires qui s'est
joué en première instance et le plus
vite possible
si nous regardons maintenant
l'itinéraire du texte relatif aux
mineurs qui sera développée par madame
tasca et madame boumédiene thiery tout à
l'heure on retrouve là mais ma cohérence
en avril 2008
madame dati pointait vous l'avez dit
vous-même tout à l'heure une trentaine
de modifications intervenues depuis la
guerre qui ont affecté l'ordonnancé du 2
février 1945 et madame dati concluait
mais cette bonne lecture
elle concluait que ces retouches
successives nuisait à la clarté et à la
compréhension et l avait mise en place
avait mis en place voilà une commission
qui est à la commission varinard qui a
déposé son rapport et ensuite ils n'y
allaient pas dans ce rapport de volonté
de modifier partiellement évidemment
lors de nos yeux 45
madame alliot marie à son tour à
regarder cet état des choses ce tableau
de la loi et a considéré que l'
ordonnance de 45 et est devenu je cite
illisible ce qui est contraire au rôle
et au but de notre droit
quelle belle ambition effectivement que
la cohérence
mais quelle contradiction puisque
aujourd'hui vous venez défendre devant
nous une nouvelle couche d'un
millefeuille législatif et une couche
d'ailleurs qu' un goût amer puisque en
réalité cette couche lavable modifier en
profondeur le sens de notre jeu
fiction des mineurs je reprends ma
question quel est donc le sens et
l'inspiration de ce double texte bien
moi je n'en vois qu'un et vous n'avez
pas le partager mais je vais essayer de
vous démontrer quel est le sens à mon
avis le seul qui puisse avoir une sorte
d' authenticité ce sens c'est la
défiance envers les magistrats
il n'ya pas d'autre sens à ce texte
acetex que la déviance la défiance
envers les magistrats et plus
généralement envers le monde judiciaire
shauna d'ailleurs que cette défiance
envers les juges
elle nous a été clairement annoncée par
le président de la république lui-même
n'ayons pas la mémoire courte il ya
quelques temps le président de la
république lui-même comparé les
magistrats à quoi à des petits pois
il y a quand même des qualificatifs plus
élogieux et le président et je cite les
comparer à des petits pois la même
couleur le même gabarit la même absence
de saveurs oui monsieur le garde des
sceaux je comprends votre délégation
mais elle s'adresse au président de la
république qui a tenu ces propos
et donc c'est le prix dans la république
qui a tenu ses propos de petits pois et
une description très précise même
couleur même gareil même absence de
saveurs et malheureusement pour lui les
petits pois ont refusé de passer à la
casserole et on voit que après laffaire
de pornic notamment les petits pois et
bien ils se sont agités où ils ont
obtenu d'ailleurs le soutien y compris
des forces de police et de la
gendarmerie
alors évidemment vous qu'est ce que vous
souhaitez faire ou les souhaitait de
nouveau les cuisiner à votre façon en
les réduisant et voulait réduisez avec
d'un côté des peines plancher ou par
exemple en matière d'immigration avec
des mesures administratives
je sais bien monsieur le garde des
sceaux que vous allez
nous assurer que cette réforme à un
autre objet qui rapprocher la justice
des citoyens
mais sincèrement regarder d'abord
l'intitulé de votre texte comme le
faisait remarquer jean-pierre michel
votre texte participation des citoyens
au fonctionnement de la justice pénale
et bien qu'est ce que cela veut dire à
la lettre que les magistrats ne sont pas
eux mêmes des citoyens et cette
formulation pour le moins maladroite
revel précisément la méfiance dont je
parlais à l'instant et d'ailleurs de
quelle justice pénale nous parlez vous
en fait vous savez la justice en deux
d'un côté il y aura la jussie qui va
traiter des délits portant une atteinte
particulièrement grave à la cohésion
sociale de notre pays et je lis ce sera
les violences les vols avec violences et
les viols les violences conjugales
habituels les agressions sexuelles les
atteintes à l'environnement et
l'usurpation d'identité alors cdi la
porterait atteinte à notre cohésion mais
si on en croit votre raisonnement est
bien la cohésion sociale de notre pays
ne serait pas menacé ni par la
corruption ni par les délits d'initiés
ni par les infractions économiques ni
par les scandales financiers ni part au
fond les scandales du monde des affaires
qui eux sera réservé à une eau justice
et cela n'aurait pas besoin de la
présence du peuple je ne suis pas sûr
que les citoyens dont vous voulez nous
rapprocher s'y retrouve
la réalité est autre et la réalité c'est
qu'effectivement vous voulez encadrer
les magistrats que vous jugez trop
laxiste par des citoyens que vous
espérez plus sévère
la conséquence est immédiate vous
limiter le pouvoir du juge qu'il
s'agisse de celui de prononcer des
peines ou celui d'accorder des
libérations conditionnelles ou encore
évidemment celui de juger les mineurs
sur les ces deux derniers points je
dirai un mot précis en fait vous nous
proposez un citoyen chasse l'autre c'est
un peu un paradoxe en matière
d'application des peines l'assesseur
citoyens assistent aura désormais les
magistrats en appel il remplacera le
représentant de l'association dinde aux
victimes et leurs représentants de
l'association de réinsertion qui
interviennent déjà et dans une match
merci complexe quel est donc l'intérêt
de remplacer un assesseur un citoyen
qualifié reconnu pour son intérêt pour
la je sais c'est et compétences par
quelqu'un qui au fond n'aura ni cette
expérience ni cette compagnie naissance
ni cet intérêt nous ne voyons aucun
intérêt qui consiste à rendre plus
difficiles les libérations
conditionnelles la même situation va
intervenir dans la justice des mineurs
mais je laisserai tout à l'heure mes
collègues vous en parler plus
précisément
j'ajouterai toutefois pour respecter le
temps qui m'est imparti
un mot sur l'étude d'impact
j'ai regardé l'étude d'impact on la
regarde rapidement elle fait une demi
page une demi-page pour l'étude d'impact
est donc consacrée aux conséquences
matérielles de votre réforme qui va
pourtant concerné plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'affaires coûter chez faire
simple j'ai pas vous donner mon point de
vue parce que mon point de vue vous
allez jugé partial
alors je vais vous donner le point de
vue de quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un qui
sort de vos rangs et je vais vous donner
le point de vue de jean paul garraud
secrétaire nationale à la justice de
l'ump et sur cette question jean paul
garraud que je connais puisqu'il est de
mon département et bien qu'est ce qu'il
nous dit qu'est ce que ne voulez pas
écouter même lorsque c'est elle qui
vient de voir ans qu'il le dit il craint
un ralentissement considérable de la
justice un risque de paralysie at il
précisé à l afp
et il ajoute que nous allons changer la
nature de la procédure et la faire
évoluer vers une procédure orale qui
exigera beaucoup plus de temps
d'audience et jean paul garraud alico de
juger car entre affaires par jour on en
jugera 2 alors peut être est il trop
sévère je suis d'accord avec vous sera
peut être pas d'eux ça peut-être 3 sera
peut-être cap mais nous voyons bien
qu'effectivement tout cela va allonger
la durée des audiences
évidemment le coût des affaires voilà
monsieur le garde des sceaux
la principale question qui se pose à la
justice et celle des moyens nous avons
un misérable 37e budget en europe dix
magistrats pour 100000 habitants c'est
dire la moitié que la moyenne européenne
trois procureurs
tweet chez nos voisins et pourtant vous
nous proposer une réforme qui va encore
à allonger les procédures et allonger
les délais exactement l'averse de ce qui
aurait été nécessaire de faire alors je
termine je termine sur une feuille
d'arbre franchement situation cinq lois
ont ainsi limiter le pouvoir des juges 5
loire en quatre ans cinq lois qui n'ont
absolument pas fait reculer la
délinquance dans notre pays
cinq lois qui ont été largement inutile
et vous allez ajouter aujourd'hui un
sixième texte ira lui des effets
dévastateurs temps sur la réalisation
des majeurs que sur la prévention de la
délinquance des mineurs
merci merci monsieur denis
maintenant nous allons écouter avec
intérêt madame anne marie escoffier pour
le groupe rdse
mais ce président monsieur garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice et des
libertés mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je m'entraînerai
dans mon intervention au projet initial
présenté par le gouvernement
projet initial qui avait pour objectif
d'améliorer renforcer ou encore élargir
la participation des citoyens assesseurs
ou des citoyens jurés à toutes les
instances judiciaires
voilà qui procède d'une juste cause dès
lors que l'ambition qui la sous-tend
respecte les principes d'indépendance et
d'impartialité de l'autorité judiciaire
et non c'est dans notre constitution des
principes dont la participation des
jurés au délibéré de la cour d'assises
est le garant garant du principe de la
légalité de celui de l'application des
lois dans le temps de
l'individualisation des peines principe
encore de la présomption d'innocence
autant de fondement qui ont fait depuis
bien longtemps le plébiscite des jurys
populaires
ajoutant au jugement des techniciens du
droit leur intime conviction
pourquoi alors rompre dans le texte du
projet initial du gouvernement ce
délicat équilibre au prétexte
d'impliquer davantage le citoyen dans la
prise d'une décision de justice rendue
au nom du peuple
si ce n'est pour répondre à une autre
ambition celle que nous propose ce
projet de loi le durcissement de nos
procédures pénales je n'en veux pour
preuve que l'omission bien
malencontreuse dans le projet présenté
par le gouvernement du principe de
présomption d'innocence dans votre
conclusion sur les objectifs de la loi
n'écrivez vous pas prévoit la motivation
des arrêts d'assises qui permettra aux
personnes condamnées de connaître les
principales raisons pour lesquelles la
cour d'assises a été convaincu de leur
culpabilité
qu'en est il des arrêts d'acquittement
notre droit et notre justice ne pas me
laisser subsister un doute
sur le respect de ce principe déjà
largement ébranlée par l'introduction du
plaider coupable
le renforcement du rôle du parquet dans
la qualité d'autorité judiciaire est
pourtant contestée par la cour
européenne en ce qu'il n'est pas
indépendant et autonome de l'exécutif ou
encore par les projets de suppression du
magistrat instructeur au prétexte
d'améliorer le fonctionnement des cours
d'assises et de remédier à la
multiplication des correctionnalisation
des infractions vous proposait de
remplacer les actuels neuf jurés de cour
d'assises par deux est deux assesseurs à
l'instance des crimes punis d'une peine
maximale de quinze ou vingt ans à
l'image du dispositif fixé s'agissant de
la procédure correctionnelle vous
instituez ainsi implicitement une
correctionnalisation légale des primes
au crime ou inversement une
criminalisation des délits de fait le
tribunal correctionnel et la cour
d'assises avec deux assesseurs citoyens
et trois magistrats ne se distingueront
plus que par leur nom les infractions
qu'elles soient qualifiés de délits ou
de crimes seront toutes poursuivi
introduite est renvoyé selon la même
procédure et sur le fondement des mêmes
règles d'audiencement devant des
instances différencier par leur seul nom
notre cour d'assises dès lors en sa
formation traditionnelle actuelle
deviendra exceptionnel est réservé aux
crimes en récidive à la faculté des
parties de s'opposer à la formation
assesseurs et aux crimes les plus odieux
qu'ils font encourir plus de 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle en proposant pareil
dispositif le gouvernement introduit une
nouvelle hiérarchie celle de l'auteur et
non plus celle de l'infraction
jusqu alors il s'agissait de distinguer
les crimes des délits et de protéger le
principe du procès équitable même
juridiction pour mêmes qualifications
aujourd'hui la différenciation vient de
la qualité de l'auteur
le récidiviste ne sera pas traité comme
le primo délinquants cette circonstance
que la aggravante devient un élément
constitutif de l'infraction qui
justifierait à lui seul non pas une
sanction plus sévère mais une
juridiction particulière et
exceptionnelle
le petit criminel aura droit à la cour
citoyenne le grand criminel à la cour
d'assises le petit criminel sera traité
comme le prévenu au total on assistera à
un renforcement de la répression et à
une aggravation des peines n'ont pas
encouru mais prononcé chacun sachant
bien la plus grande sévérité des peines
prononcées par les magistrats
correctionnel par rapport à la relative
clémence des cours d'assises
au delà ce changement d'orientation
voulu je voudrais soulever le problème
des moyens matériels et budgétaires
nécessaires à l'application de cette
réforme
par le jeu des dispositions de l'article
181 1 de l'article 240 1 et 237-1
relatifs aux assesseurs de cour
d'assises pour réduire dites-vous de
moitié les délais de détention vous
écartez comme d'un revers de main les
difficultés administratives matérielles
et financières qui vont affecter dans
leurs fondements les missions et les
charges de nos magistrats
raisonnablement l'impact positif de la
réforme sur les délais de comparution de
la personne poursuivie est peu probable
en revanche bien probable le cortège de
difficultés à venir
les désistements de dernière heure des
assesseurs le temps nécessaire pour les
familiariser avec une matière difficile
à appréhender pour le plus grand nombre
le coût des indemnisations mais surtout
il est à craindre que ce projet n'est
des incidences sur le délai des
comparutions voir sur les comparutions
immédiates elle même qui face à la
possibilité de réunir le tribunal le
jour même veron le prévenu présenté
devant le seul juge des libertés et de
la détention ou devant le tribunal
composé alors des seuls magistrats dans
l'hypothèse d'une détention provisoire
le délai de placement ne devrait pas
excéder un mois délai au delà duquel le
prévenu serait remise en liberté dès
lors en matière criminelle
alors que le gouvernement dit vouloir
réduire à 6 mois le temps de détention
provisoire qu'en sera-t-il vraiment
doit-on craindre ou se réjouir de voir
remise en liberté un accusé au terme des
six mois doit-on craindre ou se réjouir
de voir cet accusé renvoyé devant une
cour d'assises composée des seuls
magistrats est cela le progrès que l'on
est en droit d'attendre une réforme
réfléchie et penser tout laisse à croire
que vous des fêtes d'une main ce que
vous avez fait de l'autre n'ayant même
le rôle éminent que devrait assumer les
citoyens assesseurs ne tenant plus à ses
assesseurs qu'un rôle de gages de bonne
conduite du système judiciaire
j'ouvrais mon intervention sur
l'intention à peine voilées du
gouvernement de durcir les procédures
pénales
le projet de loi dans son titre 2 en est
une triste illustration les dispositions
relatives à la répression des
infractions commises par les mineurs
bafoue la qualité de mineur consacré par
l' ordonnance du 2 février 1945 la
minorité n'est plus une clause
d'exception
le mineur est ici appréhendé dans sa
seule qualité d'auteur au même titre
qu'à majeur prétendre par la création
d'un tribunal correctionnel pour mineurs
participer à la rééducation du
délinquant et soutenir que cette
nouvelle juridiction spécialisée et un
remède pour faire comprendre at-elle
jeunes adultes tels enfants la nécessité
de sortir de l'engrenage de la
délinquance est une aberration nous
quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette séance pour la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr à suivre le journal de
19h présenté ce soir par michel
grossiord très belle soirée à tous